à ce jour une seule famille a porté
plainte contre l'ehpad de pontarlier une
seule réclamations adressées à l'agencé
régionale de santé
après la mort d'une patiente dans des
circonstances troublantes la rs a mené
son enquête et ne s'exprime pas sur ce
cas précis mais elle relève trois points
contre l'établissement
tout d'abord l'utilisation trop poussée
d'une molécule un anxiolytique courant
l'établissement aurait t'il forcer les
doses
le directeur de l'hôpital a bien voulu
nous répondre pour nous nous contestons
le fait qu'elles ne puissent pas être
utilisés en ehpad son usage est tout à
fait licite reconnu par les écoles de
gériatrie là dessus nous sommes nous
pourrons défendre la position sans
aucune difficulté
deuxième reproche de la rs la
surmortalité dans l'établissement une
vérité statistiques claires et nettes
qui intrigue les autorités
la rs a donc rouvert 33 dossiers des
personnes décédées entre 2017 et 2018
la direction de l'hôpital ne comprends
pas cette suspicion
j'ai une totale confiance dans les
équipes qui travaillent dans cet
établissement
les équipes médicales tant que soignante
d'une manière générale et quant à
l'euthanasie
non il n'en était pas question il n'ya
pas en tout cas sûrement pas en dehors
d'un cadre réglementaire et légal
nous sommes où nous accompagnons la fin
de la vie normalement pratique pas
d'euthanasie un médecin gériatre et
clairement ciblé par les enquêteurs il
vient d'être mise à pied à titre
conservatoire les seules remarques que
j'ai pu avoir de la part d'un que j'ai
lus par courrier de la part de trois
infirmières aller exactement sens
contraire de celui qui est cité dans
cette affaire
la rs doit rendre son rapport la semaine
prochaine la justice devrait prendre le
relais et nommé des experts médicaux
extérieur l'enquète n'en est qu'à ses
débuts